hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
among his essays critical and clinical
gilda lou's has one entitled bartleby
or the formula and this is referencing
herman melville's short story bartleby
the scrivener that many of people have
encountered
and from which they probably
only remember the famous formula
i would prefer not to that's actually
even been turned into memes in recent
times
as well the essay that deleuze provides
us here
with is going to cover not just bartleby
the scrivener but also
connect it up with moby dick and
with billy bod with some other authors
works and eventually talk about american
pragmatism
but we should concentrate first on what
he begins with which is
this formula the i would prefer
not to that bartleby tells to the
attorney
over and over again and
the first thing that he talks about the
first point
that deleuze settles on is the
a grammaticality of this formula or
let's call it the potential a
grammaticality because
as he's going to tell us it has the same
force the same role as an a grammatical
formula but he's not committing himself
to whether it truly
is a grammatical so we have to
well what is a grammaticality what what
is this and he tells us
linguists have analyzed what we call a
grammaticality
a number of very intense examples can be
found for example
in the work of e.e cummings the poet
for instance the formula he danced his
did
as if one said in french he'll dance oh
me
he danced his began and
he goes on and says this presupposes a
series of ordinary grammatical variables
which would have an a grammatical
formula as their
limit and that's an important term limit
right there he also talks about very
briefly lewis
carroll and portmanteau words
what does that mean made up words that
sometimes are smushed together
sound like other words great example of
this would be in
carol's jabberwocky right if you've ever
read that it was brilliant and the
slythertoes did gyre and jimble in the
way
what are those words well those are
words that carol made up
and they there's a a grammaticality to
that
as well but in a different sense not all
of a grammaticality is the same
so he says that here's some other
examples
perhaps it would be better to take an
example from the french in a practical
situation someone who wants to hang
something on a wall
and holds a certain number of nails in
his hands exclaims
john a underpass i have
one not enough it's not quite said
properly
right but but it's it's understandable
at least it seems like it's
understandable and within a practical
situation you can say
that i know exactly what this guy means
but you could also be confused by it
so he says wouldn't bartleby's formula
be of this type
at once a stereotypy of bartleby's and a
highly poetic expression of melvilles
the limit of such of a series such as i
would prefer
this i would prefer not to do that that
is not what i would prefer and
he says well no that's not precisely
what's going on
this not to is the key here he says
the formula is grammatically correct
syntactically correct
but it's abrupt termination not to
leaves what it rejects undetermined and
confers on it a kind of
limit function so maybe it has the same
role
as an a grammatical formula and
a little bit later in a really important
passage
about four pages into the essay de luz
tells us that the formula at first seems
like the bad translation of a foreign
language
once we understand it better once we
hear it more clearly it splendor refutes
this hypothesis perhaps
it is the formula that carves out a kind
of foreign language
within language and then he brings up e
cummings again and says
you know if we delve into his stuff and
kind of lay it all out
we can see that there is a different
dialect here maybe that's part of what's
going on
with bartleby and then he says well it's
it's
it's not exactly a dialect he says the
rule would lie in this
logic of negative preference this
logic a different logic here so
um that's a good starting point duluz
also brings up
very shortly after that that there are a
number of variants
and circumstances in which the formula
is being used
why is he doing this in in that essay is
this just
being a literary critic and you know
showing us how thorough
he is is this part of establishing his
own expertise
being a master in a certain way i'm not
actually going to
provide you with an answer i'll just say
this is a good thing to think about
and i would suggest that the
leading clue to this is the term copy
which gets used a lot in this essay and
in the
work itself bartleby the scrivener
as one of the things that he's not going
to do right
so let's come back to this and the loose
says that there are several variants
this is an important point he says
sometimes it abandons the conditional
and becomes more curt
i prefer not to sometimes as in its
final occurrences it seems to lose its
mystery by being completed by an
infinitive
and is coupled with two i prefer to give
no answer i would prefer not to be
a little reasonable i would prefer not
to
take a clerkship i would prefer to be
doing
something else and he says but even in
these cases we sense the muted presence
of the strange form
that continues to haunt bartleby's
language
and what is he pointing at here
something very interesting and i'm going
to bring up an analogy to somebody
who you wouldn't think of bringing into
connection with the lose but when i read
this i was like oh yeah these
what's happening here is kind of the
same thing even though the referent
is very different saint anselm of
canterbury very famous for
what the ontological argument which he
doesn't call an ontological argument
and what you know readers call by that
name is only a portion of anselm's
single argument unum argumentum
but there is a really important phrase
that's a linchpin
in whatever the argument happens to be
quo mayas kogitari
known posit in latin right in english
that than which nothing greater can be
thought that then which nothing greater
can be conceived
that's a weird kind of formula sort of
like i would prefer
not to except it's referring to god
so instead of like a blank there's
supposed to be like an
infinity there and here's where it gets
really
interesting and i think there's an
analogy so bartleby uses the formula in
a couple different ways which means that
it's not
just the magic words themselves i would
prefer not to
it could be framed in other ways anselm
does that
in proselogian too sometimes it's called
maya's kogitari known posit
and sometimes it's framed in slightly
different language right
so known posit non-valiate
does it change the meaning not exactly
and you can say what's going on there
why is this like just to
embellish to make it more interesting
that's an interesting question in itself
bartleby uses the formula according to
duluz in 10
principal circumstances 10 different
places we're not going to look at all of
these he says that
bartleby is a copyist in the attorney's
office he copies ceaselessly silently
paley mechanically the first instance
takes place when the attorney tells them
to proofread
and collate the two two clerks copies
and he says
i would prefer not to so that's the
first one
the second when the attorney tells
bartleby to come and re-read his own
copies the third when the attorney
invites bartleby to re-read with him
personally tenet the fourth when the
attorney wants to send him on an air in
the fifth when he asks him to go into
the next room and it goes on and on and
on right
and he says that the formula virgins
and prolifer
proliferates there we go sometimes okay
it's funny because this is a
book in which de luz has an essay about
stuttering
and we just did that right there right
so he says at each occurrence
there is a stupor surrounding bartleby
as if one had heard the unspeakable or
the unstoppable
so this this formula is getting bigger
and bigger and bigger in the work
through these circumstances and we can
ask another question that duluz then
treats
what are the effects of this formula why
why is it it's not magic
really but it seems almost like magic
why does it do what it does what does it
do
deluse uses terms like ravaging
devastating he talks about it being
contagious
to others and it's
definitely disruptive of the good order
of the office
or the intentions of the attorney
in fact it's contagious almost like a
brain worm
and that they start using that
expression
about preferring not to and bartleby
says oh you've you've caught
it right more importantly according to
duluz
it renders actions impossible
for bartleby it i won't say traps him
but it does sort of hem him in
so he says from the moment that bartleby
says i would prefer not to collate he's
no longer able to copy either
and yet he will never say that he
prefers not to copy simply pass beyond
this stage doubtless he does not realize
this immediately since he continues
copying until after the sixth instance
when he does notice it it seems obvious
like the delayed reaction
that was already implied in the first
statement of the
formula and here he talks about a
formula block
the effect of it is not only to impugn
what bartleby prefers
not to do but also to render what he was
doing
impossible this is an interesting
thing to note it makes it
practically impossible within the logic
that bartleby's
working in something that is still
possible for you know in general for
everybody else and
there's a really great formula that
deleuze
has here eliminates the preferable
just as mercilessly as any non-preferred
so the formula doesn't just exclude
what's not being preferred it also
generates a range in which there's
there's nothing being preferred
how does it have that that force
well the cl you know the clue to this
lies in that paragraph that i brought up
before
where um de luz said the rule would lie
in this logic of negative preference he
follows that immediately by talking
about
a negativism beyond all negation
now that's a very interesting thing to
say isn't it
it's kind of
of heidegger's nothing is it not right
heidegger is nothing that is not merely
the negation of all
or each thing but is there
and cannot be grasped as a concept
but is there in all of our negative
our nothing bringing behavior
is this exactly the same thing i would
not say it's exactly the same thing
but it's certainly in the neighborhood
he also tells us that the formula
this is something you might contest he
says that the formula is neither an
affirmation
nor a negation bartleby does not refuse
but neither does he accept right he
advances and then withdraws into this
advance
um let's pause for a second is that
really true
it's not an affirmation i mean in a
trivial sense
it is an affirmation i would prefer
not to i'm asserting of myself
that i would not want to do x
yes you're right that that is in fact
again in a trivial sense an affirmation
but it's an affirmation of something
that's swallowed up by
the negation within it or the
putting something aside within it isn't
it
it's not just a negation though either
and this is where we get to something
quite interesting on a
pragmatic level he says that the
attorney would be relieved if bartleby
did not want to but bartleby does not
refuse
he simply rejects a non-preferred
he also doesn't accept either right
so he doesn't refuse or accept
that he doesn't follow the logic of the
attorneys following a different logic
and he says that he rejects a a
non-preferred
and posits the impossibility
of anything else
so he says in short the formula that
successively refuses every other act has
already engulfed the act of copying
which it no longer even needs to refuse
and he says
it not only abolishes the term it refers
to and that it rejects but abolishes the
other term
it seemed to preserve and that becomes
an impossible
here dulu says something else is very
interesting
he claims that the formula hollows out
a zone as he calls it an
ever-expanding zone of indiscernibility
or indetermination
between some non-preferred activities
and a preferable activity all
particularity all
reference is abolished the formula
annihilates
copying what does it mean to have a zone
of indiscernibility or indetermination
so indetermination means things are not
actually settled as being this or that
right
again very uh bad for office discipline
um indiscernibility
not being able to tell the difference
between things right
not being able to discern what things
actually are and what are what are the
actual things here
actions actions and volitions
and so this is quite important and now
talking about volitions brings us to a
last point that deleuze is noting here
that i think is quite important he tells
us
that here we go
i would prefer nothing than something
not a will to nothingness
though but the growth of a nothingness
of the will the will itself is
instead of driving after nothingness
taking nothingness as its
object is whatever we want to say
contaminated um shot through and through
with nothingness and therefore whatever
will is coming out of it whatever
volition
it is directing is a negating
or negative one a negativism
right and so this is a good place
to to pause does this tell us everything
we need to know
about this interesting formula
it remains kind of i don't want to say a
mystery
but something that we we have to
continue to
think through and penetrate into and
it's also got this feature of once you
once you start thinking about it it's a
little bit difficult
to put it aside
you